our next set of guests are on the ground
in arizona
see the problems firsthand let's bring
in yuma arizona mayor douglas nichols
pennell county sheriff mark lamb and
sheriff mark daniels
of help me out with that county sheriff
what is it conch ice coat
good morning pete cochise county coaches
i shouldn't have even tried i should
have let you do it
gentlemen thank you all for being here
really appreciate it mr mayor i'll start
with you
when it comes to the apprehensions and
the releasing that you're seeing right
now are you getting any input
as to how where people when people are
released uh
what is the mayor facing on at this
moment
so right now we we do have something set
up so we had some non-profits
stand up to in order to receive the
releases
do the covet testing to do the
quarantining and then transport
to regional shelters but that is just as
we're able to
keep the pace within the the
parameters or the capacity of these
non-profits if if this skyrockets where
these releases get up to the hundreds a
day
i don't really know if our nonprofits
will be able to keep pace and so as a
mayor of the city
you just try to prepare for that as much
as we can
prepare for it as much as you can i mean
that's pragmatic but
ultimately if the number if well if the
numbers spike you're admitting that that
creates a serious strain
on services that citizens in your city
use as well sheriff lamb let me ask you
this spike how unprecedented is it what
are you facing
oh this is about like it was when obama
was in there and uh it's actually worse
right now what we're facing is we're
daily we're
we're having pursuits with these folks
we're having to go fish them out of the
desert
and that's only going to increase as the
temperatures increase we'll spend the
majority of our time this summer doing
humanitarian and rescue missions with
people left in the desert
by the smugglers basically left for dead
so that's an issue for us and of course
the health issues that's one thing that
concerns our communities and i believe
that title 42 will go away soon which is
the ability to expose
expel them for under covid and once that
goes away
that's going to put all of us in a huge
predicament well an even bigger
predicament than what we're already in
it's a challenge that all of us sheriffs
are facing sheriff flam real quick
follow up with you
because border patrol is spending so
much time at these facilities processing
migrants are they
are you seeing an uptick in what your
sheriff's department is having to step
in and do
oh absolutely you know and what they've
done is forward deployed a lot of these
guys from our
our sector uh that were that work with
us
they're down on the border having to
deal with all the children and all the
other families coming across
and they're leaving wide open those
areas where the cartel smuggles in
humans and drugs and that's what i get
in my county and that's what the sheriff
sheriff daniels gets down in cochise
county as well leaving
wide open sheriff daniels not only are
you a sheriff you're also the chairman
of the border security committee of the
national sheriff's association and you
were also
on the homeland security advisory
council until it was dissolved
just a couple of days ago talk to us
about that well
i received an email on friday no
forewarning nothing
uh opened up the email was from homeland
security it was to the atac which is
homeland security advisory council
in that letter uh the secretary my
orches said
he's honored to address us in paragraph
one paragraph
two stated that uh we were being
relieved uh
unappointed because this is an
appointment and so we were unappointed
all but three members of the hsac were
terminated
from this advisory council now and i'll
say this to you p there's no better time
as sheriff lamb and the mayor said
to have an advisory council helping us
through this crisis on the border
so it was it was disappointing and
disheartening all in one
if you would sheriff can you explain a
little bit more about title 42 because
you've brought that up as well
and you feel like that's something
that's currently being used that won't
be
what does that mean
title 42 is the during a health pandemic
where only safety central travel into
the united states is allowed
and it also allows border patrol cbp
to expel them without a judicial
oversight so immediately they're
expelled back into their country or
where they've crossed at
what's happening in texas is they're not
they're not being expelled because the
state
south of texas won't accept earth uh
mexico won't accept
them snore the state of sonora south of
arizona here my county they still are
accepting them
april 21st title 42 is set to expire
when that happens we're going to be
seeing the exact same
uh problem that they're doing in texas
right now it's concerning on april 21st
what's going to happen
mr mayor real quick one of the things
you're concerned about you say
which is being missed is human
trafficking
definitely i mean at the root of all
this this is a
value that i think the country i don't
care which side of the aisle you sit on
just are not going to sit still for but
we're not talking about it enough
when people leave their home in whatever
country they're coming from they're sold
at ticket literally sold a ticket
into this country and that process along
the way
as well as when they even get to country
and they actually have to pay for that
ticket
is not a humane process as a country we
need to find ways to disrupt that
not encourage it amen mayor douglas
nicholls sheriff mark lamb and sheriff
mark daniels thank you gentlemen all for
what you do for speaking out
uh and we wish you the best godspeed
thank you thank you